we watched the joeoy Golden Globes intro
and it was fine even the Taylor Swift
joke was good and Mild he just delivered
it like a bashful ancient gisha girl you
got to bring that conqueror colonizing
arrogance that Richie Jes I'm here to
burn it down the truth is all your jokes
were good you were fine you just were a
little too Meek with it you got to take
them you're not doing it for Merill
Street you're not doing it for your mom
you're doing it for us the working man
who wants to watch these people get
on but you know I'm speaking with no
Authority because ratings were up but I
could only assume that's because every
Filipino tuned in halfway they were
going turn it off he's not confident
turn it back to the YouTube video of
Manny Pacquiao singing I'd rather watch
Manny Pacquiao singing than watch Jo KY
mishly deliver jokes I'm going back to
my physical therapy job